well you ain't from around here are you
boy part of me wonders is my southern
accent as embarrassing as my British one
I don't know
hey everybody overdue Doctor Who
continues and we roll right along with
series 7 which brings us to a town
called mercy this is an episode I have
very mixed feelings about I want to like
it more than I do and there's just a
bunch of little things kind of holding
it back for me that are not massive
glaring issues it just results in an
episode that's just kind of fine it's
just sort of the epitome of yeah yeah
yeah that was those an episode of Doctor
Who sure it's kind of all but I can
think to say about it really but I'm
gonna have to think of more to say so
let's sort this out I am rather fond of
Ben Browder I'm a Farscape fan so having
him in this playing the marshal they put
a little more dirt on his face that I
think strictly speaking they needed to
but he works I always liked him he's got
it he's got a just a very affable line
delivery and presence so I enjoy that I
kinda wish they got more screen time out
of him I feel like they actually killed
that character earlier than was
necessary to do for the plot I may only
be saying that because I like Ben
Browder though so there's that the
gunslinger I mean it's just fun you
basically got this sort of this
steampunk Western cyborg and it's just
that's just cool I like the design I
like the Reaver
they've gotten the voice I really am a
sucker for low voices with reverb I
don't know what it is there's just
something just about about when the
voices get that deep and you know just
ah bring them out or you all die
you know I man I really do love that I
like what they're doing with the doctor
here it's funny because I feel like this
episode pulls off more successfully one
what dinosaurs on a spaceship tried to
do towards the end or at least in a way
that integrations are the story better
so I mentioned in my previous review
that one of my issues with dinosaurs on
a spaceship is the shift to the doctor
you know going dark and basically
killing a guy effectively not and not
that I never want to see the story go
that way cuz you know we're we're
dealing with the doctor who seems to be
grappling with a lot right now but that
really didn't feel like the story to do
it in
whereas here his sort of struggle of
what to do with this alien who's hiding
out who put not only the gunslinger but
innumerable other people through hell
through physical mental emotional hell
in order to make weapons and the doctor
you know being torn and conflicted about
what to do to or with this guy and so
it's dredging up the same sort of angst
and uncertainty and you know certain
amount of oh jeez or we headed towards
the Time Lord victorious again fear in
the audience in a way that integrates
into the story much better especially
with him basically taking over the role
of the marshal ba in the town because it
puts him in the situation where it's
it's his call and he seems to know he's
not in the best mindset to be able to
make this call with any dispassion
and I really do like his outburst you
know today I think about the victims
first his the Daleks the Cybermen the
Masters you know the the weight of all
the damage that's happened around him
that he couldn't stop is weighing on him
I also like game is responsive seat this
is why you can't travel alone it it's
doing a very good job of iterating the
importance of companions in general Amy
in particular at the moment and just
also allowing the doctor without dipping
into that Time Lord victorious thing
again just allowing him to feel his
feelings because the man is frustrated
he tries so hard and so many people
still die like that weighs on you I get
it so I enjoy all that but there's just
I think part of what doesn't fully click
for me in this episode is the setting I
don't know I love it's just because
being an American I very much you know
grew up in the you know with the with
the iconography of the Wild West and for
me and especially the time of which I
grew up the wild what the very concept
of the Wild West was basically a theme
park like it was this romanticized thing
that was repackaged for children's
entertainment all over the place you
know he would show up either as
pastiches in cartoons or you would have
you know things just sort of set in that
time and in that era you know maybe even
aimed at at teenagers or or whatnot and
it just it I don't know it's just
something that I'm so familiar with an
associate so much with youth I think
it's just because when you grow up in
America
you kind of have to as you grow over get
the idea of the cowboy and that whole
culture demystified for you because you
realize how how many ugly truths that
glossed over so to see a show basically
have what again it looks to me like
effectively the the amusement park
version of the Wild West and just
presenting it straight I don't know
that's hard for me to connect to if you
want better with me with something like
say the Red Dwarf episode that's that's
that has a Wild West setting because
that's there to have fun and have fun
and you'll make funny jokes and just be
ridiculous with it whereas playing it a
bit more strange it's it's hard for me
to connect with that setting and take it
seriously I guess is and and that might
be one of those things that's just me
that's just my hang-up in my baggage I
don't know but I think that it's
probably the biggest knock on my ability
to get more enjoyment out of this
episode than I do there's also you know
some especially at the front end a
little bit some sort of extended cringy
humor with things like you know the
doctor walking into the saloon and he's
chewing on a toothpick really awkwardly
for a while and or you know he gets to
the guys ship and he's you know hitting
in and Wow like why is this going on for
like 20 seconds I will it's a it's not a
great joke but I did appreciate him
taking a guy's horse and the guy says
the horse's name is Joshua it's from the
Bible
and the doctor says no it's not I speak
horse his name Susan and he wants you to
respect his life choices it
there are there are some lgbtq+ some
trans sort of people who have probably
feel like it's making light of of gender
identity things by making a joke I I
thought it was loving and endearing and
it it doesn't I didn't feel like it made
Jenner identity the target of the joke
was just the topic of the joke see my
video on who gets to tell what jokes
from last year on the difference there
and they're spending more time talking
about this then is probably worth it but
I enjoyed that moment I had completely
forgotten about it
before I before I rewatched it but I
think that's about it core cast is great
guest cast is pretty good yet Ben
Browder but the rest of the core the
rest of the supporting cast is pretty
decent as well some wonky southern
accents but I mean there were wonky New
York accents and back in series 3 for
that doll liked to party so I mean I
don't know it when you know what an
accent really sounds like you just you
catch the little things that aren't
quite right so you know it's it's what
I'm gonna catch whenever British actors
do American accents and it's what I'm
sure every viewer that I have in the UK
they they probably cringing and lose a
few months off their life every time
they hear me even for a single line of
dialogue try and do a British accent
so I guess my apologies they're a town
called mercy you rewashed it lately what
you think about it whatever your
thoughts are there's a comment section
down there
put something on down let's talk about
it I've got a patreon if you feel like
supporting me and helping this whole
thing keep going and maybe even get
bigger and better and more elaborate who
knows in addition of course you can also
help me out by liking subscribing
sharing this video but you also don't
have to do any of it cuz I'm not gonna
tell you what to do I ain't the sheriff
here and at the end of the day folks
you're the council I'm just running the
meetings and until next time this
council is adjourned
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]